So here's a little issue we have in
America today.
Um,
there are currently about 250,000 people
a year who are dying in our hospitals
due to,
uh,
due to preventable deaths.
And I'm not talking about negligence,
I'm talking about little accidents,
right?
Um,
I'm talking about the doctor in the
morning,
not properly briefing the doctor for the
evening.
You know,
I'm talking about things that you,
you know,
we can't sue anybody.
There's nothing,
there's nothing that we can see that's
wrong,
but there's 250,000 preventable deaths
every year.
That's about 27,
40 sevens going down every single week.
That's what's the equivalent to,
and the confusing thing is that we have
the best doctors in the world.
We have the most advanced technology in
the world.
Some of the medical equipment we have is
the best in the world.
The medicines we have are the best in
the world.
So you start asking yourselves,
why are these things happening?
And the reason is not because of any of
those things,
the reasons are actually something
vastly more simple and something very,
very human.
5% of hospital administrators or
doctors,
most of them are number crunchers.
Hospitals are run like businesses.
Hospitals are run by the numbers.
And the problem isn't the people who are
giving the care,
they're very highly trained.
The problem is the way those people are
cared for.
Because what we've done is we've created
cultures in hospitals where the people
who were doing the caring aren't cared
for.
And so all of these little preventable
deaths are happening because they don't
feel like they're a part of anything.
They're just doing their jobs and they
don't get along that well.
And there's not a lot of camaraderie.
And the impact is death.
Right?
Now I use this example because it's
exaggerated because the impact is so
powerful.
But the problem is the same in our own
companies,
right?
Which is we come to work and were told,
you must care for your clients.
You must care for your customers.
You must make them the focus of all you
do.
And yet why aren't the people who are
managing us from the top caring about
us?
So yes,
in a hospital,
the impact is worse,
but the impact that we're having on the
outside world is just as bad.
In other words,
we're not working at our best.
We don't care for the things we're
doing.
We're not helping each other is the most
important part.
And the residual impact is that we are
unfulfilled by the work that we do and
when were unfulfilled by the work that
we do,
we focus on the details,
and when we focus on the details,
we retract from each other.
When we track from each other,
we feel lonely.
And when we feel lonely,
cancer goes up.
Heart disease goes up,
diabetes goes up.
In other words,
by going to work,
we're killing ourselves.
Literally.
There's another study that was released
not that long ago that says,
uh,
parents who work late.
The negative impact that it has on their
children is little to none.
They may feel guilty as parents,
but the negative impact that it has on
the raising of their children is little
to none.
However,
parents who come home from jobs they
hate or don't love,
their kids are more likely to be bullies
at school.
And now you think about the bullying
epidemic we have in America,
right?
Where there's this disturbing number of
young children who are killing
themselves,
suicides because of bullies.
The problem is not the schools and the
problem isn't even the parenting.
The problem is the jobs the parents
have.
This is the importance and this is the
power of the work that we do and the
places we go to work,
right?
Most of us,
I mean like if you listen to the,
the,
the uh,
the unemployment statistics,
they say,
you know,
we're all time high,
record high,
nine to 10% unemployment,
right?
And people go,
oh my God,
that's terrible.
And I hear that number and I go,
well,
that means 91% still have a job right?
Now,
granted,
we want to get that employment number
up,
but that means 91% is still going to
work.
The question is how many of them coming
home fulfilled by the work that they do
and how many of them are waking up
inspired to go back to work the next
day?
If we don't love our works,
we don't look out for each other.
And if we don't look out for each other,
we feel lonely.
If we don't feel lonely,
all these negative things happen.
So what example can I share with a
creative audience about how to change
this?
The United States Marine Corps,
I had the great honor last week of
spending a week with the marines.
I spent a couple days at camp lagoon and
then I went for a few days to,
um,
Paris island to watch them go through
bootcamp.
And this isn't a race.
It's a remarkable,
remarkable human experiment that they're
doing.
And even though they know what works,
they don't know why it works,
but they don't need to know why,
because they know that it works,
right?
But what's happening is they're taking a
group of strangers,
people who don't know each other,
who are showing up and within a very,
very short period of time,
learn to trust each other so much that
they would give their lives for each
other.
Right?
And we know everyone,
sort of,
anyone who's ever worn a human form
knows that no one runs into battle for
God and country.
It doesn't happen.
It's for the guy to the left of me and
the guy to the right of me.
That's the reason they do what they do.
Right?
And these sort of remarkable stories of
heroism where people rush into very,
very dangerous situations to save
others.
And they always ask the question,
why did you do it?
Why would you risk your life?
Why would you put yourself at risk for
them?
And the answer's always the same because
they would do it for me.
In other words,
what gives him the confidence to put
themselves at great risk is the
knowledge that someone would do the same
for them.
We would put ourselves at great risk for
our companies if we knew that our
companies would put themselves at great
risk for us,
but they don't.
So we don't.
Now,
one of the things that's remarkable
about the marines,
and if you go read and you know this is
the most I asked these young and 2122
years old,
some of these are these lance corporals,
the grunts,
you know the guys,
the infantry,
I mean this is the lowest of the low.
The ones we actually send into battle,
the front lines and I asked them,
are you misunderstood in America?
And they said,
yes unanimously.
They all nodded.
I said,
what?
What did people think of you?
And one stood up and says,
they think we're baby killers.
I said,
how does it feel?
He says,
it hurts.
And when I say,
well,
tell me a story then that captures to
you what it means to be a marine.
The feeling you have of being a marine.
Tell me a story that captures it and I
expect it to hear stories of I took a
hit and somebody saved me or I ran into
a firefight can pull somebody.
I expected these stories of heroism,
not a single story like that came out
and I'm sure those stories exist,
but those aren't the tall the stories
they told me that capture what it means
to be a marine.
One of the stories they told me was a
young boy in Afghanistan who would come
around every morning and sell kabobs to
the marines and then one day he showed
up and he was all beaten up and he
didn't go to his parents for help and he
didn't go to his friends to help.
He came to the marines for help because
he trusted them more than anyone else.
They told me a story that captured how
they feel of a civilian edge that had
been overrun by the Taliban and the
residents of the village could,
couldn't go home because they would be
killed by the Taliban and so they were
just living by the river.
The problem was winter was coming and
one of the uh,
the elders came to the marines,
knocked on the door and said,
I need you to come down to the river and
kill us.
And the marines said,
what are you talking about?
He says,
if we go back home will be killed by the
Taliban and if we stay out there,
we're going to die slow deaths this
winter.
It's easier if you just come and kill us
please.
The marines overran the Taliban village,
push the Taliban out.
A year later they went back to this
village and people were playing
volleyball.
These were the stories they told me that
capture what it means to be a marine.
They believe in doing good for others
and the fulfillment they get when they
put themselves at risk so that others
may prevail is overwhelming.
This is not unique to the Marine Corps.
This is all human beings.
The feeling of fulfillment comes from
doing something for another.
The feeling from fulfillment comes from
the exertion of time and energy for
someone else.
If you are walking to work and you
throw,
throw a few pennies in a cup and you
come to work and you say to your
friends,
hey guys,
I gave a dollar to somebody homeless
this morning,
what are your friends going to say?
A good,
right?
I gave 20 bucks to somebody homeless.
They'd be like,
ah,
good for you.
Right?
What have you come in in the morning?
You say,
Hey,
I gave up my Saturday and I went and
paid and as painted a school in the
inner city,
people go,
Whoa,
cool,
wow,
cool.
And all of a sudden,
not only are they inspired to do
something good themselves,
but the feeling that you have persists.
The amazing thing is that when we do
good for others,
that actually inspires others to do good
for others.
This is provided for us,
it to logically,
anthropologically it's all part of the
survival of the species.
You know,
sex feels good,
so that will do it.
So we can procreate and perpetuate the
species,
but we're social animals and so we have
to provide for the fact that we'll
maintain strong buns and build cultures.
Right?
Because that's what humans do.
We're cultural animals.
And so when we do good for others and we
look out for those in our tribe,
we look out for those in our group.
It actually feels good biologically.
It releases oxytocin.
This chemical that's released when you
do good for others is released and it
makes you feel good.
And the amazing thing is the more
oxytocin you have in your body,
the more you want to do good for others.
The problem is we've replaced this
feeling,
the exertion of time and energy with
digital communications.
We've replaced it with headphones,
we've replaced it with money,
right?
Think about the invention of money,
It used to be money.
You know,
it used to be like you go to someone's
house,
you cook them dinner,
and the deal was they'll do the dishes,
time and energy exchange for time and
energy.
And someone said,
I'll give you an Iou,
right?
Someone says,
I don't feel like doing the dishes,
so I'm going to give you an Iou that I
promised to do them another day,
right?
And that's what money is.
It is the promise for future goods or
services,
the promise of future goods and
services.
In other words,
we've replaced our own time and energy
with promises for someone else to do it
another day.
Right?
In other words,
there's no exertion of time and energy.
And so the feeling people get is that I
did something for you and you did
nothing for me.
You replaced it with a piece of paper,
with an Iru,
with a promise for future goods and
services.
The way we find fulfillment is by doing
good for others.
So how did the marines it,
how do you get people to do good for
others?
We all know this intellectually.
We know that it's good to do good for
others,
but why don't we do it then why don't we
do it?
And what the Marines learned is
something that I completely did not
expect.
They kinda just yell at these guys to
help each other.
That's not what happens.
There's a few things that they have to
do first.
So we all heard of the obstacle course,
right?
The marines have a thing called the
obstacle course and this is where they
build anaerobic strength and aerobic
strength,
muscle strength,
and it's timed and all of this good
stuff.
They have another course called the
confidence course and it's never timed
and most of the obstacles on this course
cannot be completed by yourself.
They must be completed in teams.
You have no choice.
That's just how it's designed and what
they say is the first two weeks of
bootcamp.
Everybody's there to outdo each other
and prove that there's strong.
Just kind of like when we start on a
job,
we're proof.
We want to show how great we are.
We'll work a little harder,
we'll do good work.
Look how good my design is,
right?
It's all about us and how good we are,
But they keep putting them in situations
where they can't do things by
themselves.
And what starts to happen very slowly,
they said after about two weeks,
they start cheering for each other.
Now they get in trouble when they do,
but they start cheering for each other
and then before too long you see them
organically start helping each other and
what happens is if there's one person
who's weak and refuses to help each
other,
the others,
or even if there's one person who's
strong,
who's,
you know,
I was the star college athlete and they
get to every,
the end of every obstacle and they just
stand there and wait for everybody to
finish and they don't help each other.
What starts to happen as organically,
the group starts to ostracize that
person organically.
They get ostracized until they learn
that the only way that they will get
through this thing,
they only way they will survive bootcamp
is if they ask for help because they
have no option.
The problem is no one will help them
until they're willing to help another.
It's the deal we have to make.
It's called vulnerability and risk.
We have to take the risk to make
ourselves vulnerable.
Yes,
you might do something for someone else
and they may not do something back for
you.
That's the risk you run.
It's not about,
it's not about giving everything to them
and and sort of huge,
big,
overwhelming risk.
It's about little things and little
things.
It's like going on a date,
right?
He's like,
if I went on a date with somebody,
I came home and I said,
uh,
I'll have to one day,
and I said,
I'm marrying her.
They'd be like,
what?
Are you nuts?
I'd be like,
I'm in love.
They're like,
but you're here.
This is crazy.
I'm like,
I know I'm in love.
She feels the same way.
We both know it's nuts right now.
You know that you're going to be like,
go on a couple more dates.
Right.
We know instinctively that the strong
bond that's created that that needs to
be created first takes more than a week,
right?
We know that.
Right?
But if I've been dating somebody for
seven years and we haven't,
you know,
married,
you'd be like,
dude,
what is wrong?
Right?
In other words,
we know that it takes more than seven
days and we know that it takes less than
seven years.
The problem is we don't know how long it
takes.
Somewhere in the middle.
All human bonds are the same.
Like when you show up at work,
when you show for the first time,
when you're new,
don't expect that people will look out
for you and they won't expect you to
look out for them in seven days.
It won't happen.
But if you can working at a job for a
few years and you don't have the
[inaudible] sort of the,
the absolute confidence that if you turn
your back,
you will not get stabbed.
You can rely on somebody,
you can give them something.
Nothing will go wrong.
You will share the credit.
No one will throw you under the bus if
you don't have that in a few years,
something's wrong,
something's wrong.
I don't know how long it takes,
but I know that's more than a week and I
know it's less than seven years,
and the marines fundamentally understand
that before anyone is willing to put
themselves out for another,
they have to have self confidence,
real self confidence.
You have to be confident in yourself and
your own ability before you're willing
to help another.
If you're insecure at all about your own
ability,
it's an oxy.
It's sort of a paradox,
right?
How am I,
how can I overcome my confidence?
You know,
my self confidence and we all have ego
issues at all times.
You know,
we all do,
right?
But if I'm not confident in myself,
I won't help another.
It's a paradox because then we need
someone to look out for us before we're
willing to help our peers,
right?
This is what management is supposed to
do.
The drill instructors,
the school they are,
there are parents.
They're there for one reason and one
reason only to help us feel strong and
good about ourselves.
But look at the way we talk to each
other.
A look at the look.
A budget's been cut and so what do you
get told?
I need you guys to do more with less,
right?
That's what we're told.
Hey guys,
I need you guys to do more with less.
That's what it told by our clients,
by our bosses,
by our parents.
This is what we're told,
right?
That's like your parents telling you
when you're young.
I know you're stupid.
Figure it out.
Right?
You're not as smart as the other kids.
What do you want me to do?
Right?
It's the exact same thing.
I need you to do more with less,
right?
What we need to be telling people is I
need you,
I need you to do more with what you
have,
right?
You have capacity,
you have strength,
you have talent,
you have compatibility.
I need you to do more with what you
have.
We don't celebrate what we've got.
We criticized for what we don't have.
This is the responsibility of management
to take us under their wing and help us
understand our own value to ourselves.
Close your eyes and think back to high
school and think of that one teacher who
took you under their wing and cared for
you and looked after you and helped you
realize that you are capable of more
than you thought you were and you and
you.
You probably are the person you are
today in some part because of that
person,
right?
Do you have that name?
What's the name?
Tell me the name.
Tell me the name of the teacher.
Okay,
give me the name.
we can,
I can point to anybody and you can tell
me that name.
Now,
tell me the names of all the other
teachers you have that day.
Can't remember them.
Kenya.
This is the power of those who teach us
confidence.
We will literally carry their names
around with us for the rest of our
lives.
Wouldn't you want to be that person?
Wouldn't you want to be the person that
20 years from now,
30 years from now,
40 years from now,
I can do this exercise with somebody and
they will tell me your name.
Yeah.
This is the power of helping others
realize their own strengths.
This is what management and leadership
is supposed to be doing.
They're supposed to be caring for us and
helping us realize our own value.
And by the way,
if you have anybody who reports to your
work for you,
your responsibility is not to make them
meet the deadline.
You're responsibility is not to make
sure that they do.
As you say,
you're responsibility is to make sure
that they understand their own
strengths,
their own value,
and that they are way,
way more talented than they think they
are.
And the only way they will learn that is
that you put them in situations in which
they can fail.
And you hold them and you support them
and you give them talent and you give
them skills and you'd give them
education and you watch their backs and
if they fall over,
you encourage them to get back up.
And if they follow the,
you character them to get back up.
And if they fall over,
you encourage them to get back up until
they figured out themselves cold
confidence.
It's your responsibility to help others
find it to others.
Responsibility to help you find yours.
And the amazing thing is as soon as you
start feeling confident in your own
ability,
you're naturally help each other.
That's what happens.
It's called trust in the military.
They give medals to people who were
willing to sacrifice themselves so that
others may gain.
In business,
we are willing to give bonuses to people
who will sacrifice others.
So that we may gain,
we have it backwards and then we
complain about how we don't love our
jobs and we complain about how the work
is suffering and we can plan about how
budgets are being cut and we can
complain and complain and complain and
the first thing we do is blame each
other and become more selfish and
worried about my pay and my benefits and
my this and this is what happens when we
are unfulfilled.
We look at the metrics and we say
they're not good enough.
When we are fulfilled,
we don't care about the metrics.
This is why when you have a job you love
and you get a call that says,
I'll offer you tons more money in great
benefits you like,
I'm not interested,
I'm not interested.
I'm very happy here,
but we'll give you more.
That's not the reason I'm here.
I'm here because I love it.
I'm here because I care for the people I
work with and I'm here because the
people I work with care for me.
This is the world I imagine.
Yeah,
this is the world I imagine.
And here's the great thing.
If you take little risks,
I'm not talking about big things,
little things.
If you start doing little things for
each other,
the amazing anthropological response is
other people will start doing little
things for others too.
I was walking down the street two days
ago and a guy's backpack was open at a
whole bunch of paper,
fell out as he's walking down the street
and I happened to be behind him.
And so my friend and I just sort of,
we were in mid conversation and in mid
conversation we never even stopped
talking.
We just bend down,
sort of helped him gather his papers.
I hadn't them back to him,
sort of pointed out that his book bag
was his,
you know,
his backpack was unzipped and he said
thanks.
And we walked down.
It was like no big deal,
right?
We get to the end of the street and we
stand at the that we are waiting to
cross the street.
We're still talking,
we haven't stopped talking and the guy
in front of us turns to us and says,
I saw you help that guy.
That was really cool.
But here's what's great about that.
The guy will go do something for someone
else simply because he saw us bend down
and pick up paper for someone else.
He will actually go do something for
someone else because of it.
Right?
He,
he won't give to charity because I,
he sees me put a dollar in a cup,
but he will actually help someone
because he saw someone also helps
someone.
Little things hold a door open for
Say thank you to the person holding the
door open for you.
Smile to the Barista.
Little little things,
you know,
put your foot in the subway when the
door is closing.
So someone who's running,
we'll make it hit the open at the,
at the elevator.
Don't go
or pretend you didn't.
See that's the best one,
you know.
Uh,
I didn't always,
I wouldn't if I saw sorry.
Alright,
do it a little time and a little energy
and you'll find around work that people
give a little time and a little energy
back to you and you'll give a little
more time and a little more energy.
You go for coffee with someone,
then you go for a two hour coffee and
you go for a coffee and a lunch.
Then you go for lunch and a dinner.
Then you go for a dinner and a movie,
and then you sleep over,
and then he'd sleep over two nights and
then you go on holiday together and
eventually you get married.
Right?
It's slow.
It takes time.
And we can't rush it.
You know,
if when we rush it,
it's all fake.
Do things for others and watch.
Watch how much others do for you.
But you know,
you go get yourself a cup of coffee from
the coffee shop machine in the morning,
make one for someone else.
It takes a little extra time.
It takes a little extra energy.
That's the point.
And here's the best part.
You will feel so good at the end of the
day.
So good.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
it's a great question.
How do you convince someone,
how do you know,
said,
what are the metrics?
How do you convince a skeptical audience
of this trust metric?
Um,
you don't,
right?
You can't twist anybody's arm to do
something that they don't want to do.
And you know,
the law of diffusion,
which I obey,
you know,
as hard as that,
as much as I can,
which is you don't need the majority.
You need those people who believe what
you believe.
In other words,
if you buy,
if you,
you know,
when you go sort of,
when you do some nice things for people,
they may not do something nice back
because they may be,
you know,
we live in a world in which you do
something for somebody.
They think you want something from them.
Right?
That's unfortunately the society we've
created.
But,
but that's the risk that we keep taking.
And I'm not saying you should keep doing
it for somebody who keeps doing nothing
and keeps sort of,
you know,
crapping on you because of it.
Then at some point you have to be like,
all right,
my bad,
my bad.
Right.
And you back off.
You know,
I don't believe in helping everyone.
I do not believe in it.
Right.
Um,
this is not,
you know,
let's do good for everyone in on the
planet.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Mother Teresa,
who is the poster child for giving
selflessly to all who need at the end of
her life,
started questioning the existence of God
and by the way,
hated her life serious.
Okay.
In other words,
giving to others unabashedly is actually
self destructive.
It doesn't help.
Right.
And it's just like going on dates with
people you don't like,
doesn't mean you'll eventually click in.
Right.
There's,
there's only one machine that I found
that really accurately measures trust
better than any other sort of metric.
It's called the human being.
It's really good at it.
Right?
And so those feelings,
you get trust them.
And one way or the other,
you know,
it's the little risks.
It's the butterflies,
it's the,
I'm unsure.
You know,
it's the,
it's the backwards with the dance.
It's dating,
it's the dance.
It's the nerves.
Like I,
you know,
it's that.
So if there were,
if there are cynical bastards at your
office who,
who are,
who,
who don't get it,
ignore,
ignore him,
don't worry about it.
Because eventually you'll get enough.
And those people either come along or
leave or be pushed out,
you know,
ostracized.
Remember when the group starts helping
each other,
they ostracize the ones who refuse to
help,
whether they're strong or whether
they're weak,
they get ostracized until they learn,
until they learn that they cannot
survive without the help of others.
And they learn that the only way others
will help them as if they,
if they help the others.
Right?
The order matters.
I'll just,
I just thought of something that,
that sort of is pervasive in our sort of
digital world.
Uh,
the order matters,
you know,
so to speak honestly about what you
want,
right?
If you are doing,
don't do things for people when you want
something from them,
just ask them what you want from them.
And I'll give you one little example.
It's a funny little example.
We've all received emails that go like
this.
Dear Simon.
Well you wouldn't get an email to their
assignment,
but I dear,
insert your name right.
Dear Simon.
Um,
haven't seen you in years.
Hope you're well,
congratulations on all you've been
doing.
It's really amazing.
We should get coffee sometime.
If you could do me a favor,
I'm,
if you could vote for me on this
website,
I'm hoping to win,
you know,
some thousand dollars prize for my
design,
blah,
blah.
Hope you're well.
Talk to you soon Kenny.
Right?
We've all received an email like that
and how do we respond to it
right now?
What happens if you get the same email
that goes like this?
Dear Simon,
I'm hoping you could vote for me on this
website.
I'm trying to win some thousand dollar
prize for my design.
I haven't seen you in years.
I hope you're really well.
Congratulations on all that you've been
doing.
We should get a coffee sometime.
Thanks Kenny.
Totally different.
In other words,
when we know why you're emailing and it
comes first,
it has a remarkable impact.
We know that all those pleasantries are
just buttering us up to get to what they
want,
right?
But if you come right out with what you
want,
we're actually very grateful for the
pleasantries,
right?
It's the same thing in human
interaction.
Don't give someone a cup of coffee.
If you need a favor back,
just ask them for the favor.
It builds trust.
I can't trust you.
Every time you do something nice for me,
I think you just something what you
want,
something from me,
I won't trust you and this is what
companies do to us,
right?
When we did this for you,
why won't you do this for us?
That's not how it works.
Generosity,
bending down to pick up the papers,
holding the door open for someone is
expecting nothing in return ever.
You do not give,
you know,
this is what happens in new business,
right?
We beat new business is built on
relationships and so we build the
relationship,
build the relationship,
build the relationship until we're
comfortable to ask for the business.
In other words,
you were only befriending till the point
you felt that I would let down my guard
and you could ask me for something the
whole time.
You were just waiting for that time.
It doesn't work that way.
If you actually want to build
relationships,
you build relationships without wanting
anything and that's how you build trust.
You want to know why the marines gave me
this incredible access?
I mean literally they said,
Simon,
anything you want to see,
you got it.
Anything you want to do,
You can go.
We went past sign that said no
observers,
no civilians beyond this point.
I'm like,
can I take pictures of like,
go ahead.
You should see some of the pictures.
They're unbelievable,
right?
I'm like right in their marines coming
at me.
We went out to the crucible and we're
all like,
you know,
they're like rolling in the dirt and
like,
you know going under barb wire and I'm
I'm not joking either.
They're like,
you know,
unprecedented access access that
journalists would be jealous of.
Do you know why they gave it to me?
Because in all the time that I've been
visiting with marines and having
meetings with them,
I've never asked for anything.
I don't want anything and I don't have
anything to sell.
I just keep showing up and say,
what do you need?
How can I help?
And at some point they said,
when I called him and said,
I need a little favor cause they know I
haven't been waiting for the favor.
It's the time now that I have a little
favor.
They go absolutely whatever you need.
It's called human relationships.
Companies don't do business with
companies.
People do business with people.
You know,
your company didn't win.
Ibm as a client,
somebody who likes somebody said,
we'll hire you.
And if they didn't like you,
they're just,
you know,
they're,
they're playing roulette.
Well,
we're betting that,
you know,
this whole workout,
those are the weak relationships.
Yes.
The more we give,
the more it inspires others to give,
but the more selfish we are,
the more others become selfish around
us.
And so those are organizations in which
selfish behavior prevails.
And so we see the residual effects,
which is they make decisions that
ultimately screw us.
They destroy our economy because of
their selfish behavior.
Right.
We know this is what,
what,
what happens?
Same in politics,
right?
Um,
uh,
and the answer is don't worry about it.
I know it sounds silly and you said you,
you,
I mean your first question is do I talk
about these things to them?
I will talk to anyone who will listen,
you know,
but I don't talk to people who don't
want to listen.
The good news is there are some good
eggs and there are some of them who've
had conversions where they were the
bastards who believe in firing people in
screening people to advance their
careers and something happens.
I just met a guy recently,
he was a very senior executive at very,
very large company and something
happened and he like,
he got like hitting the head or
something and he realized,
holy cow,
I have to look after people.
Right.
And they become obsessed with it and
they start sticking their necks out and,
and we just need those champions
scattered around.
And this is what I do.
The more I spread this message,
the more sort of it's,
it's kind of like,
um,
you know,
in the,
in the cartoons you sort of,
the whole of justice,
you know,
that the message goes out and they all
sort of like,
you know,
wherever they are.
Like,
you know,
that they'd poke their heads up.
It's that kind of thing.
The more we talk about it,
the more we put it in our work.
The,
you know,
because don't forget you're going to
help someone who goes home feeling good
and their husband or their wife works in
the bank and they're going to talk how
much about they love to,
and that might inspire that person.
You know,
it's,
it has all of these residual impacts
that,
that we don't really know.
This is the funny thing about the
Internet,
which is we're so proud of the internet
that we can measure everything.
No,
you can't.
You can only measure one layer.
Right.
So for example,
we say,
Simon,
what's the impact you're having?
I don't know.
Is The answer right?
I know it's,
it's,
I know that it'll take more than a
weekend.
I will take seven years,
but I don't know when it's going to
happen.
And I don't know how it's going to get
there.
Right?
All I can do is,
is do it right.
But I have no clue how or when.
And so for example,
I can measure book sales and I can
measure how many hits.
And I can measure how many people have
watched a ted talk and all of this.
But I can't measure,
you know,
that Ted talk being shown to a room of
50 people and one of those 50 people
doesn't buy a book,
doesn't watch a Ted talk,
doesn't do anything but goes out and
does something good for somebody else.
I have no way of measuring that.
And so we're so proud of the internet
and its ability to measure everything.
But we're measuring one layer where we
used to measure no layers.
It's like,
you know,
this is how people work.
It's,
it's,
it's Gossamer,
you know,
it's networked.
Um,
and so the answer is don't worry about
them.
Don't worry about them.
Worry about the people who you can care
for,
who you can give to.
And when we reach a critical mass in
society,
it will tip,
right?
And if you don't believe me,
the reason it is the way it is now is
because it tip the wrong way.
There was no such thing as massive
layoffs as,
as business strategy prior to
[inaudible] in the 1980s.
It just wasn't done.
It was done here and there,
but it wasn't strategy.
The idea of using layoffs to balance the
books is a relatively new phenomenon
that came for the increase of
selfishness in the Gordon Gekko greed is
good.
1980s,
boom.
Right?
Um,
and uh,
this was also the same exact period,
the 1980s,
where the theory,
the theory of shareholder value was put
forwards,
right?
Because they had all of these people
buying large companies and installing
professional managers to run the
companies that they bought,
that they invested in and they had a
problem,
which is those professional managers
were paid for by the company and those
professional managers cared for the
employees and the customers.
And so the investors said,
how do we protect our investments?
We've got an idea,
we're going to give them equity in the
company and bonus them based on the
performance.
Right.
And so the shift happened where the ceos
started caring more about the investors
and stop caring about the customers and
employees.
Those with theories introduced by some
Harvard professor in the 1980s.
We can push it back the other way,
right?
We can push it back the other way.
Um,
but we just have to,
and there's just a,
there's a,
there was a,
uh,
just the other day.
Which company was it?
Uh,
one of the large banks where the
shareholder is Citibank.
Citibank,
yeah.
Citibank.
The shareholders voted majority
shareholders voted against a fat pay
package.
That's unprecedented.
It has never happened even in hard
times.
Even when the company is doing this,
the shareholders just,
it's just sort of a,
uh,
a cursory thing where they approved the
$15 million bonus for the CEO.
They voted against it.
It's non binding,
but it sends a shot across the bow
saying shareholders now want you to be
bonused if you do something good for
others,
even if the others is us.
Right.
The point is,
is that it's starting to crack.
And so let's just stick our finger in
the crack,
you know,
make sure that it keeps cracking.
It swung one way.
We can swing it back.
The question was,
can I talk about celebrating
accomplishment while still asking for
more,
right.
Um,
to,
to so,
so,
um,
they did a study on kids who are really,
really smart,
like an older gifted classes.
Why is it when you're smart,
you're gifted?
When you're stupid,
you're special.
Why is that?
I was told my whole life I was special.
It's not never gifted.
Um,
uh,
they took the gifted kids who are
constantly told,
you're so good.
Oh,
thanks for that.
I knew you'd do well.
Oh,
you're the,
you're our best employee.
You know,
you're best student.
You're awesome.
Right?
And what happens is later in life they
actually suffer because they're very
afraid of taking risk because they're
very afraid of losing their position on
the Mantel.
Okay.
Kids who were sort of more average,
who constantly are rewarded,
not for their accomplishment,
but for their effort,
great effort,
really proud of the improvement you
made.
What they find is they do very well in
life because there's no shelf.
There's always more.
There's more effort,
right?
And so you want to reward and
acknowledge effort.
Even if they don't hit the goal,
it's that the delta.
But at the same time,
if it goes backwards,
you'd be like,
dude,
what's going on?
It was like,
we don't get,
we shouldn't be giving ribbons for
everyone who competes,
right?
Because what we're teaching people is if
you do nothing,
you get a medal,
right?
And the funny thing is,
is we start,
we're creating a generation that's
feeling very hollow and feeling,
you know,
this sense of entitlement that people
complain about Gen y the entitlement is,
I don't feel like I've accomplished
anything.
And the funny things about human beings
is we,
we,
the,
the way we feel accomplished is when we
exert energy and time and reach a
destination,
right?
And the more energy and time that we
have to suffer through,
especially if we suffer together and we
get somewhere,
it is overwhelming.
Think about the best jobs you've ever
worked on.
Was it the best design?
Was that the best results that the
company had because of your,
your project or was it an absolute hell
project that you worked together and you
came out on the other end and that you
got it done at the deadline and you're
like,
that was amazing.
It was the hell projects.
It was the things that we had to go out
of our ways more,
do things for each other,
right?
Things we weren't thinking of doing.
I was wrapping packages I was doing that
aren't designers on supposed to do
going,
you know,
this is what produces that,
right?
And so the,
the,
the thing is about measurement and
destination reward.
Imagine we're standing in a big empty
room,
right?
And we're standing in one corner and I
give you a simple instruction.
I want you to go to that corner in a
straight line,
right off you go.
No big deal,
right?
Without telling you,
I slip a chair in front of you.
What do you do?
You go around the chair.
Now you just disobeyed what I told you
to do.
I told you to go to that corner straight
line.
But this is the amazing things about
human beings,
which is when we're given a clear
destination,
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own problem
solving abilities to overcome obstacles
to get to the destination.
In other words,
the destination is more important than
the root,
right?
We are flexible about the route.
We are obsessed with the destination
reset.
We're standing in the corner together
and I give you a simple instruction.
Go somewhere in this room,
in a straight line,
and you say to me,
well,
where do want me to go?
I'm like,
I dunno,
you're smart.
Figure it out.
Go on a straight line.
And so you pick a point and you start
walking and without telling you,
I put a chair in front of you and what
do you do?
You come to a grinding halt and I say,
what'd you stop for?
You Go,
well,
you put a chair in front of me or you'll
make a sudden turn,
I'm going in another direction,
right?
And this is the problem.
It's the same obstacle.
The differences.
When you have a clear set of clear
destination,
the obstacles become easy to overcome.
When you don't have a clear destination,
you keep coming to a grinding holt.
And what we do in our companies is we're
counting the steps we're taking along
the route,
but we're never looking at the
destination,
right?
So companies has made $1 million this
year.
We were only planning on making 800,000
is like we took 10 steps.
We only planning on taking eight.
Where are you going?
No clue,
right?
We count the steps.
And so the point is,
is that people want to feel that the
effort that they're exerting actually
are moving somewhere.
And so successful measurement,
successful recognition is not just for
the steps you take.
It's not just for the effort,
it's that the effort you exerted moved
us closer to where we're trying to get
to.
And that get two should be some crazy
ideal.
My ideal is to live in a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired to go to
work and fulfilled by the work that they
do.
And the,
the,
the couple of measurements that I use
are,
if the book is selling.
And I,
by the way,
people ask me,
how many have you sold?
I have no clue.
I've never asked the publisher because
they don't care.
I really don't care how many I sold.
What I care about is the Amazon rankings
and that those are going steady or up
and not plummeting because that means
other people,
right?
Cause I don't have a publicist and I
don't have a marketing strategy on
purpose.
I didn't hire one of those companies to
sell the book for me.
And the reason is,
is because I'm not interested in book
sales.
I'm interested in the spreading of an
idea.
And so I just used that as a metric to
help me understand,
am I sort of marching in the,
because the more I preach,
is it resonating?
You know?
And so you have a couple of these
imperfect measurements that help you
understand are you going along the way?
So it's not just great effort.
Look what you achieved because that's
what we're doing now,
right?
Our goal is to increase top line
revenues by $50 million for what reason?
Right?
Which is we have to know the
destination,
and then we say,
amazing.
You took us that much closer.
And if we go to the right,
it's because we were overcoming an
obstacle.
If we hadn't gone to the right,
we would've been stuck forever.
Thank you.
You know,
it's not always straight lines.
It's not always straight lines,
but it's in one direction.
She's pulling the cane out.
Thank you very,
very much.
Yeah.